German Chancellor Angela Merkel has gone
into home quarantine after a doctor who
treated her was diagnosed with the
corona virus on Friday Mackel who is 65
was vaccinated against a different virus
by the doctor who later tested positive
for kovat 19 makkal spokesman says she
will now undergo daily testing her last
act before going into quarantine was to
announced sweeping restrictions on
freedom of movement and social
interactions Angela Merkel about to
announce the most severe restrictions on
freedom of movement seen in Germany
since World War two the corona virus
continues to spread rapidly convincing
the Chancellor that further containment
measures are needed so far it had
largely been left to states and
municipalities to curb the contagion
creating a patchwork of rules and
guidelines the new measures will be
rolled out across Germany via Dobermans
looking we have discussed today how our
countermeasures are working we have no
vaccine and we have no drug against the
disease all we have are firstly the
efforts we are making to prepare our
health care system especially hospitals
for the expected continued high rise in
infections and secondly our own behavior
that is currently our most effective
measure middle that's rehab in a
videoconference
Merkel and state leaders decided to ban
gatherings of more than two people
excluding families and housemates she
thanked the population for observing
measures and guidelines already in place
advice
I know that it entails sacrifice both
economically and on a personal level
when shops have to close and it's not
possible to socialize it's even more
painful not being able to visit
grandparents or meet friends we all have
to live without this for a while I am
deeply touched that so many people are
following those rules that's be with me
Zia
within an hour of miracle leaving the
press conference news she was going into
quarantine broke the Chancellor has put
herself at the front and center of
Germany's response to the pandemic
Angela Merkel now gets to lead by
example well for more let's cross
straight over to our political
correspondent Kate Brady Kate Angela
Merkel is now at home in quarantine what
does this mean for her and her ability
to govern well so far we know that she
will be continuing to work at least as
much as possible from work now the
cabinet meeting the usual Monday cabinet
meeting will be taking place today and
she will be participating most likely
via video or by a telephone conference
call but the the idea is that it will
very much be business as usual here of
course there's still constant changes
here in Germany to be dealt with
possible new measures later this week
but particularly when it comes to our
financial aid as well here in Germany
we're expecting to see a supplementary
budget come out this week of up to 156
billion euros and that would be around
43 percent of Germany's normal yearly
budget so there's still a lot to be done
here in Germany and of course Angela
Merkel will be trying to participate in
as much of that as possible while she
remains at home in self-quarantine
when will we find out Kate whether the
Chancellor actually has Kobe 19 well all
we know so far is that the government
spokesperson Stephan's I but actually
said yesterday that Angela Merkel will
be tested regularly in the coming days
but so far we don't yet have a test
result but of course that will be
published and made public as soon as we
have it now just before it was announced
that Chancellor was going into
quarantine she announced new
restrictions on movement and social
interaction tell us more about those
restrictions
well one of the biggest new measures is
that groups of more than two people are
now banned in Germany now excluded from
that new measure are families and people
that that you might live within a house
sure for example but this is a big
measure that's being implemented
nationwide today now people are however
still allow to travel to the grocery
stores to work if they can prove it
they're on their way to help for someone
for example but of course this is also
been implemented in different ways
around the country as well for here here
in Berlin in the in the state city-state
of Berlin for example local authorities
police here are asking people to now
carry some piece of identification on
them at all times as well so that they
can check indeed where they live and and
see where they might be going but we did
indeed over the weekend see a decrease
at least here in the capital of people
gathering in large groups it seems that
people have started to listen here and
adhere to the advice that's being given
not only by health express but also by
the German Chancellor Angela Merkel so
stay at home wherever possible because
right now the implementation of these
measures and stayin at home and reducing
the risk of spreading this virus as much
as possible is all about winning time
and flattening that curve to minimize
the spread of kovat 19 okay thank you so
much that was our political
correspondent Kate Brady